do you hear that sound Chris Sims I
don't that sound is the stomping of feet
rumbling back left coast Beach the gap
is closing Chris Sims are you nervous
Bendrick tell them how much ground I
made up last week made up a lot of
ground left go tell em about that right
now in the bank accounts Chris Sims 640
bleacher bucks Adam let go 260 bleep
landslide boy I don't do math in my head
300 and double that's what it is
last week I was down 1010 this week I'm
down 380 oh man you got saved by
Jacksonville get in the push gosh that
really saved me I'll tell you what I hit
chargers Seattle Green Bay
bang-bang-bang
750 50 right there came by the office
cam and Lauren came by the office last
Sunday right Adam was here by himself
and I asked him how it was and he said
Adam was just pacing around losing his
mind alone oh gosh it's so I'm so glad I
don't have to be here at Sunday's
anymore it's so great we need to swatch
one game together now we don't what were
you doing the playoff Superbowl yeah
let's just keep the streak alive just
never watch a football game together
again right it's over sorry
we're done on Sunday I'll be honest you
talk too much during games so it's
probably for the best
I'd love that you don't like when people
talk and you were the number one talker
and bleacher report for four years well
yeah well cuz we talked about different
thing no weed yeah you're dumb who knows
what it was it was just dumb [ __ ]
constantly I don't know all I know is
what would Chris say when he'd come in
20 minutes late and I'd fill him in all
the games thanks man you really
appreciate you 20 late and left go would
give you a download on seven games at
once yes no no that was the great that
was great yeah and Josh's brother was
like how does that even happen oh and
then your friends and then and then of
what I loved is that you got mad at the
guy who talked after you would be the
one that was talking for the our
previous to that then the guy started
some we had some guy come in to talk and
then you'd get mad at him because he'd
be like ah I shouldn't play them on my
flesh
I don't care about your flex I know I I
really just want to watch games by
myself all the time locked in a dark
cave I at this point of the year I've
watched every game either by myself or
with Josh right and then the times that
other people have been in the office
me and Josh look at each other and go we
need to get rid of them - yeah I guess
this is the only place but you can watch
all the games this is why you come here
I could set up if you go on Instagram
Simpson left Kyle usually show the setup
I can put I rank my games I got three
games out there I got one two and then
red zone and then I got two games on the
right so I got four games in red zone
and then I know how to use all the
controls now so if I if one gate like
Bengals Saints popping that one off but
right one on right but it's it's hard
you're what three or four games at once
yeah I can go five at once
yeah I put one in my laptop for in the
TV an NBC you're doing everything
everything yeah it's a pretty good setup
everything is too much some tight is too
much I always cancel games out I'll be
honest as someone that has to talk about
the NFL to people that care about the
NFL at this point the reason I even put
the audio up on red zone is I'm just
realizing a lot of NFL fans get their
football from red zone and it's I
watched Twitter too and it's really
funny to watch Twitter react to a
touchdown that just went up on red zone
when it happened a while ago right and I
go you know because I care about how
people consume the game as put then also
making it happen but I had a big run I
felt really good about it how did it was
awesome how did Sims do a guaranteed to
lose I guaranteed to lose Sims was three
and two last week hit the Bengals
Cardinals and Raiders lost the Titans
and Browns so overall 38 and 12 were the
two shocking games of the way I could
deal with that
yeah sometimes it happens you want me to
read this email before we get going and
left collogues went to one and one to
one and one right okay yeah read this
email so we got this email last night
from our listener Reece coin man I think
is how you say his last name I probably
screwed that up kind of long but it's
pretty great so here's what resent us
last night thought I'd share my gambling
story with you guys as you helped me it
all started with two parlays totaling
$30 some of the bets were the Saints to
beat Baltimore and the
Panthers against Philly I won and made
750 I live in Sydney Australia it's hard
to watch the NFL live especially as a
Packers fan because getting to Lambeau
would be so expensive after I won I
realized the Packers were playing in LA
that week thought [ __ ] it rolled 750 on
the texans game it came off and i won
2,200
what texas game this would have been the
week before packers rams so i don't know
which game that was i got it
Thursday Night Football finished at 2:30
p.m. Sydney time on Friday I bought a
plane ticket jumped on the plane
Saturday watch the Packers in LA on
Sunday it was incredible I left 100 of
my account made more bets with
suggestions from your gambling show it
was the Texas Dolphins I think on that
Thursday know either that or the Broncos
those bets won me 1200 so as I walked
out of the Coliseum I bought tickets to
the final game of the World Series
grabbed a lift straight there and was
able to watch Boston win the trophy I
was also lucky enough to get tickets to
watch the Lakers in the LA Kings all the
tickets to the games and the flights for
were paid with my winnings it was
amazing thanks so much for your tips
guys they do make a difference you also
give out great info of how games break
down which is great knowledge for player
prop bets mmm I like it this guy all
expenses paid now I'm Sydney to LA right
so the Packers the World Series the
Lakers and the Kings off of advice from
this gambling there's any ones out there
that's lost their house because of our
send those emails into did you know that
Florio wrote an article apologize are
not apologizing but saying that he
shouldn't you shouldn't take his
gambling advice as gospel oh I heard him
talk about it yes because he got a
complaint from someone about the Eagles
right Cowboys game right he said the
Eagles were gonna win they lost a
month's salary yeah yeah what well I did
an interview it's gonna be in a podcast
with awful announcing and they were
talking about gambling and I said look
I'm just gonna break it to you I don't
bet with my own money anymore because
through this show I've realized how hard
it is to bet on the NFL and I can't
imagine really risking a ton now if I'm
gonna have fun with my friends I'm gonna
bet absolutely but if you don't have the
means do not do it it's not smart
because I'll tell you what that ball can
bounce a funny way and all of a sudden
you don't cover and it's it's crazy you
know I have fun doing it but I don't bet
my money anymore I used to but not
anymore
I'll bet we used straight up on a game
like if we disagree on one today I think
we should do another $20 bet okay ready
to get going yeah of course I'm ready to
get going against Chris Sims so head I'd
love to double double the loser of me
am I going for four in a row or three or
five in a row four in a row right two in
a row we haven't done spreads two years
in a row other thing was five games a
week that job I'll go for three hours
yeah first game of the week Thursday
Night Football the four four and one
Green Bay Packers taking on the four and
five Seattle Seahawks spread in this
game Seattle - two point five Chris Sims
take it away um okay Thursday Night
Football game both defenses not very
good at stopping the run that is
certainly one thing I look at I have I
don't really put in any so there's only
one team that can run the football and
they this matchup though I'm not putting
stock into the green baize run defense
yet not yet I mean you can run offense
you're not gonna see one game of Aaron
Jones to go things right you know and
there's a little bit success against the
New England Patriots who played a game
really just to stop Aaron Rodgers and
and there they had some success - so I
gotta see it before I buy into that
Thursday night scary I also think about
the game you know hey in Seattle it's
one of the hardest places to play Green
Bay can name this is the interesting
part of the game they're both coming off
emotional games or emotional runs Green
Bay's late this is their fourth week in
a row a playoff game and last week don't
be fooled by the score of 31 to 12
against the Miami Dolphins right
you loved it it was very close right
like it was like 14 at 12 something like
that right in the fourth quarter right
early and then it was a bad Brock
Osweiler interception ie the Packers a
short feel exactly then they got that
quick touchdown and just compound that
it's exactly right and the Dolphins they
just don't play smart football no they
don't
they don't you're exactly the bads they
had the bad snap on the first drive
right all that stuff so I again you know
don't look at final scores context of
games does matter at times of course and
you know then they came off of course
that Patriots game before that which was
a must-win and the Rams game was a
must-win right so I look at that that
can take an emotional toll on your
football team now on the other side the
Seahawks are really done the same thing
if as Chargers must-win Rams must-win
and they lost both of those but the fact
that they're at home and it's the
Seattle Seahawks yes I
favored them in the matchup now the
things that scare me to a degree and it
actually this goes to both sides
like I know Green Bay sacks the
quarterback a lot but neither one of
these teams have great pass rushers or
great athletes on the edge which always
can scare me to a degree with these two
quarterbacks because then they can be
capable of taking over in those type of
situations can be fun for us it will be
a fun watch I know you're really fun
game I agree last night at the end of
the day though I am taking the Seattle
Seahawks and I am betting $200 on it I
know maybe a little aggressive I'm not
sure but I'm going with the a little
good bet the Thursday night and let me
tell you yes I have a stat that I'm
gonna make you I'm just gonna I'm going
to Seattle 15 okay I've just decided I
don't want to talk a lot about the
Thursday games anymore yeah no no no no
no I sound like an idiot the next day if
we're wrong if Green Bay wins this game
we're gonna sell I get it so I'm just
not gonna tell ya here is the stat right
one Chris Carson's back which is huge
right in the last 12 years yeah
teams that fly two or more time zones
west for a Thursday Night Football game
yeah have never won or covered Thursday
Night Football
wow this happened earlier with Minnesota
the Rams remember they did not cover
they did not win they lost 38 to 31 okay
11 times those teams are own 11 straight
up makes me feel better
111 against the spread guy is a Packers
team that's Owen four on the road and
they've given up a hundred and forty
point six yards per game on the ground
since week six fifth worst in the NFL
I'm going deep I got Seattle won in 24
21 what was your score
oh my score was 32 21 you have a pretty
sizable I see it being about your score
and Seattle hunch in one in late like
going on a drive that wears the Packers
out with a run game I really think this
could be a fun fun game I hope so
I really do let's go they got some cool
history these two teams you know some
recent history and they got two
quarterbacks that I think are you know I
think you and I would agree or capable
of being the greatest one-man bands on
the planet hundred percent so alright
guys first game on Sunday the five and
four Cincinnati Bengals I know all the
visiting the four and five Baltimore
Ravens spread in this game for now we're
gonna call this a pick'em because Joe
flacco status is still up in the air if
a line if his status is announced and a
line does come out we're gonna trade Tex
and we'll post a screenshot of our
conversation how we do a line comes out
yeah it's three or less right I think
the BET stand if the line comes out and
it's a bigger line then I think we need
that okay I'm cool with that Chris take
it away um I'm changing my betting my
betting strategy this week you had a
left go esque crisis like I'm sick of
losing $50 on some of the games where I
go ah you know cuz 50 is like no so I I
went to ten on some of these you're
gonna say you're gonna tell me you
already know why this guy talked so much
crap yeah oh you're kidding you didn't
make a $10 bet this week yeah this guy
good luck staying ahead of the trend
right you'll be back on the tens next
week after I win all right yeah I don't
know I to be honest we talked about this
before the show yeah a lot of these
games I feel like I know where they're
gonna go but which means I know nothing
so go ahead I don't I don't so I totally
lied to you earlier when I was just like
yeah yeah I know yeah I feel good about
it yeah well then I feel really
confident
all right bangles and ravens okay
alright I guess the first thing is I
mean the quarterback situation of course
we don't know what the hell's gonna go
on am I crazy to think that I think
they're gonna play both quarterbacks if
Joe Flacco doesn't play like I really
think they're going to if I'm them
that's what I would do I would go you
know what rg3 starts the game Lamarr
you're gonna get a plenty of snaps to
we're gonna put you both on the field a
lot of different times and I would think
they'd have with some ID they're smart
they should have some crazy plays in the
game plan this week we're RG 3 and Lamar
on the field at the same time here say
how do the Bengals know what to prepare
for exactly that's what that's where I
like that's from that standpoint and hey
don't forget Lamar could be quarterback
and rg3 can do the same things Lamar
does when he's not the quarterback and
runs speed saves in fact he's faster
than Lamar so that's where I think it
could be cool just from that aspect
you're right no one's talking about RG 3
all week right so I mean to me that's
either Jo or or four or G or Lamar right
I would trust RG three if you made me
start a guy I would go it should be rg3
if you're just gonna play one guy I do
think they should play both and I do
think that they should play through
through their strength which is their
own line as well and come up with some
creative run stuff and these two guys
can run and do that and guess what the
Bengals defense stinks okay thanks I
mean it's horrible just fired Terrell
off right so I just I have no faith in
what the bangles are in a football team
I'm picking the Ravens okay for $50
I don't think this hello mr. Raven how
are you it's good to see you again but
yes I have no faith in the Bengals at
all as a team and you know AJ Green that
whole situation the bank
the Ravens coming off a bye week
certainly in a desperate situation
I said Ravens 2217 when a team gets
shall act like the Bengals did last week
yeah what do you think normally happens
next week I'm just curious what you
think I don't know I mean no I oh well
what do I think happens the next week
that the team puts one of their best
most spirited efforts together of the
year right I just feel like I mean they
win these teams are coming off of like
demora like the Baltimore Ravens have
just been using a lot before the bye
right the bagels really have owned this
series yeah I know Heaton - in the last
10 and you remember earlier there is a
chance that AJ Green might play but I
don't think so he did not practice today
it just came out on Thursday okay so I
don't think AJ Green's gonna play
Baltimore their last four weeks after
the bye they've won three of them I
would not be surprised at Baltimore won
this game big I really would I hear you
because I think that they're the better
team and I think that they're a team
that has something to play for right and
I know that cincinnati is gonna go we're
the six seed man you ain't to succeed in
any universe and more importantly they
signed Hugh Jackson so like what does
Hugh Jackson do like I yeah they're
losing man they're losing I love that
comes back to here I had it a hundred I
brought it down to your exact betting
$50 in Baltimore
huge you've gone Smeagol lately on the
raven you gotta let go you got it come
on we're done
the raven man yes flying over Cincinnati
yes you have to start off with your Sten
you get the boy you Jackson is taking a
stand yeah um I think that Baltimore
could beat him with Lamar I think they
can beat him with rg3 yeah I think they
could beat him with Joe Flacco without a
hip you can get a hit replacement go out
there on a hospital bed
I think Baltimore is the better team
yeah and I look at Cincinnati and their
defense is just so bad so and if AJ
Green doesn't play if AJ Green doesn't
play the Tyler Boyd routes aren't there
anymore
yeah the John Ross all the pressures on
him and he ain't nothing right CJ Zoma
ain't doing anything at tight end yeah
and Joe Mixon ain't running on this
Baltimore defense I feel like this is
gonna be the game that I look back and
go I wish I put more than I nouns
I know yes what was your score I did 22
17 but I got 26 217 yeah I mean I wanted
I've thought about like Oh heavy but I
think the history of Cincinnati has and
I stopped I got a quarterback
uncertainty I kind of chickened out
there were there were too many moments
but I just go and the Ravens are such a
better team um yeah all right guys next
game on the Sunday slate here the four
and five Dallas Cowboys on the road
visiting another five and a Falcons
spread in this game Atlanta - three and
a half Chris okay so where do I start
here okay so first of all this is not
gonna be like last year don't look at
last year okay eight sex right Adrienne
Claiborne was six sacks because Tyre and
Smith was out Josh green right exactly
disaster so somebody looked at last year
yeah so a little Tyron Smith right now
miss practice with backs pass yeah that
could be an issue
right I mean if he misses I don't even
know what to say by either way though
this is where we'll start off Alana's
offense hey it's good we know that
Dallas defense is very good we're home
really quick just you know there's like
50% of these games
were teams that played last year and I'm
very curious how much that impacts this
year so each game that this happened
right I'll bring it up but that I mean
this was that was the twenty seven two
seven Atlanta beats Dallas yeah Barris
is right yeah yeah no it's all good oh
good I know in that I thought about it
too as I was picking the game as a
Google wait man that was not a good
matchup for Dallas last year but you
know I'm taking this as Tyrone Smith is
going to play as of right now but Dallas
is defense versus Atlanta offense this
is where it's different than last year
right off the bat I mean Dallas is D is
the real deal
I mean there's all three levels and I AB
set it and I will say again the
cornerback duo for the Dallas Cowboys is
as good as anybody in the NFL it's a
special duo
Colin Collins Chris Collinsworth right
like Byron Jones the best press corps in
the interface he's in that discussion
he's Jalen Ramsey ish I mean his body
makeup is that we know what he did the
combo exactly foot broad jump he's a
freak show
so he's been phenomenal and I do I think
they can match up and slow down this
Atlanta attack on that side of the ball
I look at the other side of the ball and
I go men if Dallas just kind of stays
with the power run game and does things
like that I do think they can move the
ball and overpower Atlanta's front seven
rushing yards per play well yeah I think
Atlanta's defense is ranked mmm I
wouldn't think it's good thirty first
yeah because it's rushing yards to play
is a nice stat for them because a lot of
the teams especially when their defense
was really struggling didn't even want
to waste their time rushing because they
were like we can get 20 yards per pass
so why would we run like that so that's
what scares me they're okay I know
you're trying to move along here um I
think this game is a very 50/50 dollar
game I am going with the Dallas Cowboys
okay I don't think they're gonna win the
game I'm betting $10 on the cowboy yes
but I don't feel I could see the Cowboys
winning this I'm going twenty three
twenty thousands I'm only picking them
cuz they're home and I just Dallas is
such a rollercoaster that I decided to
go with Atlanta there who do you have in
this 50 $50 game that was a funny one
then I say 50 $50 yeah so of course it's
scary that the Cowboys are one in four
on the row but I'll tell you what they
look damn
in Philadelphia last season I think it's
interesting when a team gets embarrassed
in a place they're gonna want to go back
there and prove them wrong the Cowboys
are coming off of a super emotional win
the Falcons are coming off of a super
deflating loss that advantage in my mind
goes to Atlanta yes I already told you
what you said Atlanta's run defense
stinks right there are also 29th and
sacks per pass attempt so DAC will have
time right to let some plays develop
with Amari Cooper and all that Dallas is
linebackers how do they love to defend
Sims side to side line how do the
Falcons run the ball mostly its side to
socially outside to me I went they're
gonna run right into Dallas as deep
right Falcons average over 32 points per
game at home
Dallas averages just over 16 points per
game on the road hey that's advantage
Atlanta yeah but I don't think I'm not
sure if the Cowboys have faced a passing
attack like the Falcons have all year
right but this is also one of the better
pass rushes I think the Falcons are
gonna take I have the Falcons winning
this game 26 to 23 mm and I got $50 on
the Cowboys to cover this spread yeah oh
that could be content not this week not
gonna do it but I I think that this is
this in my mind could be a Dallas win
yeah
but I I think that it will be close
because I just I think as the game keeps
going on Matt Ryan with some more
opportunities is gonna put some points
on the board and I'm not that confident
yet but I could totally see Zeke owning
this game and Matt Ryan struggling but
I'm gonna 3.5 kins win which is a cover
it we're together all right guys we got
a good one for you here in the New York
area on Sunday the 3 & 6 Tampa Bay
Buccaneers on the road visiting the 2 &
7 New York Giants spread in this game is
Giants -2 Simms over to you really quick
yo this was a game that they played last
year Eli ran a little bit they went down
they scored the touchdown they got the
lead and then the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
came back and kick the field goal to win
the game that's right I remember that
game another another one in Tampa yeah
and it's now we're back in here put
another third matchup that happened last
year yeah that's funny I didn't even
think about that kind of correlation
between last year and this year
all right I mean Tampa's defense stinks
we know that I will say as far as the
matchup on that side of the ball you
know Tampa's linebackers can run maybe
they can slow down say qualm Barkley in
the pass game to a degree I think if I
think about another advantage maybe
Tampa could have you know Tampa's d-line
is not it's it's a formidable Bunch
where they have the possibility of over
running that Giants right side of their
offensive line to a degree but I was
definitely more impressed with how the
Giants protected against the 49ers last
week that was one of their their better
jobs they've done all year and and the
49ers Dean line is not you know no
pushover they've got some guys that are
big and have some size I look at that
and go okay I am of course scared of the
Giants and their ability to make big
plays with Odell se Kwang's erling
Shepard all the weapons
Tampa's defense doesn't have a lot of
talent on the back seven nor does it
have a great scheme either I also look
okay flip it over to the other side and
I go the Giants defense you know I don't
know what the Giants defense is I really
don't it's a little bit all over the
place
oh go tree getting beat here right Kylie
exactly there yes not doubling
playmakers like George kid oh yes and
then they have weeks where they slow
down the Atlanta Falcons and I go oh
okay that was not a bad performance by
them and they're just they're a little
bit all over the place to me from that
regard this game scares me I mean if
anybody was thinking about really
betting real money on this you need to
go to the psychologist and evaluate
yourself okay don't don't bet on teams
that are unpredictable and do stupid
[ __ ]
I mean Tampa Bay move the ball down the
field on the Redskins last week every
Drive yes every Drive it ended up with
three points for the game they're the
first team ever
right 498 total yards and three points
that's us for the game I never knew that
about you I right after you after I pick
it so here I go I'm Petty I'm taking the
Giants for $10 $10
that sounds like section 236 where I
used to sit for giant some games but yes
I'm going Giants 2421 ok so you know
what's really funny is we're agreeing
with each other
yeah but my questions are giant
sorrowing for at home talking to our
sound guy Nick eg the Giants do seem to
play better on the road it is funny when
they're away that Eli seems more
comfortable falcons gain they move the
ball this past week san francisco we had
a little bit of life all right
Eli is going to have time in the pocket
so should Fitzpatrick but the reason
that it's really funny with the tip of a
bucks is can the Giants keep up with the
pace of this offense at anybody because
they move the ball timba Bay is really
bad at turnovers there now - 19 so that
that Washington game four turnovers to
miss field goals yeah they got a team
that can drive down the field and it's
humphreys for 15 and godwyn for 20 and -
Sean for 12 and then Fitzpatrick decides
I'm gonna fumble in the middle of field
I'm gonna just throw it over here
he gets down to the red zone he shits
his pants it's unbelievable right so I
in this game I'm also going Giants for
$50 huh so we're all we're all aligned
right now except for the I guess that we
agreed on every victory to me there's no
money in a week one no but yeah I mean
but yeah exactly but those three games I
am NOT gonna be betting small anymore
because in my mind the Baltimore
Cincinnati game the Atlanta Dallas game
the Tim of a Giants game were a bunch of
teams that are inconsistent yeah I don't
know what we're gonna get right I
believe from here on out there are more
consistent teams playing but I'm lock
stop stop with you right there lockstep
with you what did it what was your score
I
I have the Giants winning 27 24 okay so
you have three points were there what
did you have
24:21 so even our spreads or someone yes
there you guys are in lock stop with
each other alright moving on to the next
chance has given us any of the weather
you've seen that movie Lock Stock and
Two Smoking Barrels right know you've
never seen that movie who's the main
snatch
yes it's the puzzle degree it's the
movie before snatch by Reggie Guy
Ritchie Moo it's great movie you like it
sure yeah
I love snatch yeah this is just as good
as snatch if not better just know that
we know whether yet I haven't pulled up
if you guys want it do you want the
weather in the games well if it's
interesting okay
none of these ones are that interesting
so don't worry well we're going down to
Florida now though which is always
interesting this time of year alright
next game on the one o'clock slate on
Sunday these six two and one Pittsburgh
Steelers on the road visiting the three
and six Jacksonville Jaguars spread in
this game is minus five and a half the
Steelers are favored opened at three and
a half whether in Jacksonville on Sunday
partly cloudy high of 73 Chris okay
um-hmm Pittsburgh's offense first
Jacksonville's defense
hey Jacksonville's defense is not the
same as last year there's just no other
way to say it the first thing is is
their front four I mean their front four
last year was on pace at one point to
break the all-time sack record this year
they were called Saxon ville right this
year their 27th and football in sacks
hmm great formula for one of the best
cell lines in football that basically
never gets Ben Roethlisberger hit that
scares me from that point of the matchup
also this is the most complete offense
that Jacksonville's how to play all year
long I mean you know Steelers can do
whatever they can do anything they're
successful run team accessible pass team
pass protect doesn't really matter all
you want to play one-on-one okay great
do we know what the status is AJ Booya
is he play was at practice okay he was
limited but there's a good chance he's
going to be there they need him because
I don't think they're ever gonna get
pressure on Jacksonville unless they
play take some chances man-to-man and
blitz the Pittsburgh Steelers from time
to time hey this is gonna be a
last-ditch effort for Jacksonville I
mean this really could be it they lose
this game I mean they will really have
to have miraculous things happen and the
AFC South and everywhere else for them
to get anybody to say it's done okay I'd
also like for us to get credit for not
having Jacksonville and the Eagles
making a run this year yeah I know I
think I might have had Jacksonville in
the playoffs but not winning the AFC
South I can't remember I meant I know I
said I thought they could start out bad
but the 1 & 3 thing right
but I think I did act I ultimately had
them in okay so that's that side of the
ball the other side of the ball
Jacksonville's offense
hey Jacksonville's offense Leonard
fournette he was bet good last week he's
still not a hundred percent for my money
from what I watch them film and you know
lenders yeah right so I know he's out
there oh line is not as good as last
year to begin with as is Pittsburgh
defense is rolling right now they're
they're really are they do all the
little things their defensive line is
very good as far as creating pressure
havoc they've really started to dominate
football games in a major way
and I'd like the way they're secondary
and and there's the way they're coached
you know again they've become one of
those teams left go where I look at and
go man the guys are dropping in the
right way they take the chance to play
man-to-man in the right situations so I
look at all that I am betting $50 on the
Pittsburgh Steelers hmm how come solo
yeah and I think they're going to win
27:20 because it's still Jacksonville at
home desperate they have a they match up
decently with the way Pittsburgh wants
to be the bully on the field and I don't
know I just I guess I'm a little scared
of Jacksonville's desperation there but
like I said Steelers 27:25 the Steelers
are five and OH straight up and against
the spread in their last five the
Jaguars are Owen five and straight up
and against the spread Wow last 15 road
games Pittsburgh this is just straight
up 13 1 and 1 Wow
I'm gonna go a hundred and fifty dollars
here on Pittsburgh and the main reason
I'm feeling confident your score was
twenty seven twenty by my score was
twenty eight eighteen so the reason I
feel confident in like the 18 I don't
know how you get to 18 like I was
sitting here being like I guess if like
they go for two and they don't get it a
bunch of field goals a touchdown again
three field us no that doesn't work that
yep that's Texas man maybe a safety all
right so what I came down to was when
you when I bet heavily on Jacksonville I
watch them every second of that game
right and I know they're gonna be better
at home but what I saw out of that
offense was nothing
yeah I saw Blake board
getting 80% of his yards on dump downs -
Carlos hi TJ Yeldon and maybe two
screens - Leonard fournette
yeah Leonard fournette did have some
gaps but he wasn't hitting those holes
that hard yep Pittsburgh is flying right
now yeah I mean I'm watching bud Dupree
joyfully taking levian bells bells
cleats he's not worried right I'm a
little bit worried about Connor coming
off these concussion-like symptoms there
I'm a little bit worried about Stefan to
it not practicing yesterday but I don't
have confidence in this Jacksonville
offensive line I know that bortles is a
lot about better a little bit better at
home and AJ booyah Beck I agree with you
that I still could see Jacksonville
flying all over the place and making
this crazy
yeah because Pittsburgh wants to line
out and go he's faster than you and he's
faster than you and he's stronger than
you were gonna push it it's not a lot of
scheme a lot of the time no I just think
eventually Jacksonville's not gonna be
able to do anything yeah and and I want
to put my money on the team that I think
is rolling right now and it's trying to
fight for the Steelers could honestly
get home-field advantage
they're looking at right now the Chiefs
playing in LA and go I'm in the Chiefs
lose that game yeah we're right there I
still gotta play the charger I think
this I think the Steelers are going I
love this game I'm going 150 dollars in
the Steelers but I have a question for
my personal fantasy league yeah right I
have Jacksonville's defense yeah the
only reason I'm thinking about keeping
them is because they play Buffalo next
week and that sounds really nice but
should I pick up the Giants defense
against the Buccaneers I don't know what
the Giants defense is but I feel like
Fitzpatrick might get me a few turnovers
or should I roll with Jacksonville man
that's a tough one that's they're both
dangerous they were there and I'm not
picking up the Bengals I think I would
still roll with Jacksonville all right I
don't know I just don't trust it i don't
know i don't trust the Giants I don't
either
I mean I don't trust I don't trust
Fitzpatrick either oh wow that's a tough
one I don't know what to tell you keep
talking oh yeah I mean I don't mmm as I
think about it more and more actually
I'm going you know what you should
probably go with the Giants okay yeah
but what about Jax I get scared with
Jacksonville I get scared with
Jacksonville where they could like the
AFC divisional game
where they can make some plays but then
Ben could throw for 470 yards on their
team how does the points work with the
defenses it won't be great if that
happens yeah that's what would scare me
is that more than anything so I think
you go with the Giants but I'm thinking
I could take a risk this week and then
get Jacksonville against Buffalo no you
can't get them back I guess after that
yeah because everybody's gonna wanna
yeah yeah I'm thinking I might take a
risk with my defense okay hey roughly
real quick with your bortles thing too I
think you know you talk about the plays
like I didn't chart it play for play he
had 26 completions I'm gonna tell you
that I would say 20 of them were screens
dump offs or boots in the flat and then
there was only five or six throws that
were actually dropping back throwing to
a wider drives at the end of the game to
make the comeback well Paul dump off and
when you look at it and you look at the
receptions we had five catches by four
net we had six catches by TJ Yeldon so
that's 11 of the 26 right there yeah
come on yeah all right guys immediate
Scout immediate self Scout from two
minutes ago Sims you picked the Jaguars
to win the division this year left go
you had them in the playoffs as your 6e
okay okay moving on next game of the
weekend he's 6 and 3 Houston Texans on
the road visiting 6 & 3 Washington
spread in this game is Houston minus 3
whether in Maryland on Sunday it's gonna
be a high of 49 mostly cloudy
can I ask Josh a question yeah so we're
now five games in yep and we've picked
the exact same team yep
when you hear that when you're thinking
about making your picks do you trust
that or does that scare you um let's
wait till the end of the show to have
this conversation because I would like
you guys to see how this unfolds cuz I
know what's coming
but you guys don't did do go ahead Chris
okay I love this game all right so yeah
this is Houston
Washington Redskins um okay so where do
I start here with this the let's start
off with Washington's basic offense
against this incredible D exactly right
but in this Washington basic offense
with a banged up offensive line against
one of the best most favorite physical
chaos creating front 7s and all of a
football
son of the ball is gonna be brutal too
long I would think so and then you know
if there's any way to make plays on the
Houston Texas defense it is in the past
game but damn Washington's not gonna
make them in the past game together this
group there's no way everybody's
everybody's banged up and they're not
that good anyway so I I just I have a
hard time looking at Washington's
offense being able to pass protect
Texans run a good scheme on the back end
they do creative things in the past game
I think Washington's pass offense is
also a little bit predictable that way
so that doesn't play out for them you
know there's also no actually physically
gifted weapons on the Redskins pass game
so when they need to play man-to-man or
do something they'll be able to do that
then I flip it over and we Shawn Watson
Bill O'Brien versus mineski with a bye
week right and like okay if I have one
caveat about this now the Texans offense
can be a hair you know predictable and
Mineski as we know when you're a little
bit predictable a course can can make
things confusing for for a quarterback
but to say that also man
Washington's off defense was not good
last week I mean as we just talked about
I mean it was a lot of big pass plays I
mean just chunk pass plays 15 10 2015 5
8 10 25 I mean it was unbelievable so
that scares me and Houston has enough of
an offense that I still think like
there's enough creativity there to where
they're gonna be able to take advantage
of some of those zone coverages also you
know again the Redskins as singular guys
they don't have great pass rushers that
scares me against somebody like dion uh
deshaun Watson not even Kerrigan
Carrigan's good but I don't look at him
as like a special ed guy you know he's
gonna do everything what right he's got
good hands he's got a decent first step
he does everything good but nothing
great and not athletic enough to where I
think he can contain a Watson on a
regular basis and I like the Houston run
game as well to that you know so I look
at it from that standpoint and go man
Houston's only favored by three I'm
taking the Houston Texans obviously for
$750
brought that bull okay [ __ ]
I hear you dear me oh there I am
um yeah I just I just look at this
matchup I'm putting a hundred and fifty
dollars in the Houston Texans all right
so I'm rooting for myself because I'm
making that a left go lock for sure like
this this was one the only thing I'm
worried about is cuz I knew you nailed
it
I look at Washington at home yeah and
some people sleepwalk in Houston
but this game is just so perfect because
Washington is this scared offense and
this defense that's like please run
right at us and let's do this and it's
like this one week with a bi where you
got Demaryius Thomas a settling in now
and DeAndre Hopkins can beast any of
those guys yeah and and I look at this
running game with deshaun Watson who can
create on his own which I think that's
what happened to Washington's defense
last week because Fitzpatrick can
scramble and then Watson is like what
Fitzpatrick would dream to be in his
entire life right and I look at
Washington and I'm like I don't know how
they survived that about Tampa Bay we
expected them to like fall apart last
week but they got four turnovers and two
missed field goals Houston should not
make those mistakes what was your score
here I picked 27 217 Texans I had mine
at 23 to 16 and then I made it 23 to 19
which was still a cover yeah but I yeah
I got a hundred and fifty on this one
it's I just don't see Washington's
offense getting anything done anything
unless they get a Carolina game where a
wide receiver fumbles two in their own
zone setting up easy place Chris
Thompson isn't practicing Jameis and
Crowder's not practicing Jordan Reed
could have a day but I just don't see it
don't see it either it's one of these
games right a chance of Texas come out
rusty file by I wouldn't expect I mean
they're playing for something they
finally got us on the run I mean they
got it on a roll they got confidence
they're playing smart football on both
sides yes I and if you look at the stats
damn it if you look at the stats to like
offensive ranks and diva or you look at
it and go wow this is this is close like
it's close from that standpoint even but
it's not if you're really watching
football I feel the same way I just go I
just don't see how it happens maybe I'm
wrong
we'll see ah you have no fear III I know
you you're not worried about this game
at all I I'm not worried about it no I'm
not I'm really not I'm not I will be
totally this will be one of the shockers
of the year for me if this game ends up
really close in the fourth quarter like
I will be shocked alright so how did
this discussion about this bet go before
about this bet so this week we sat
together
he put a hundred on the board for every
team which is what I always do and then
he just started because I have the dock
where it calculates it so then he
started picking games knocked him down
to ten so he picked a bunch of games
knock those down and then I tell him
alright you have seven hundred and
thirty dollars left to play with so we
originally had seven hundred and thirty
on this game and then Chris said I don't
like the way that looks 7:30 drives me
crazy yeah it drives me crazy when it's
not an even number one that when you're
in the car your radio if it's like if
it's on 13 you put it down the 12 yeah
I'm always 14 or 12 definitely yes like
my brother I purposely get in the car
and put it 250 I don't know why 15
wouldn't bother me it's just a nice
round number 11 yeah even I wouldn't
want 14 on there I actually probably
would skip 14 and 13 and go to 15 I
don't see you like the five random
numbers like Chris Sims lock of the year
currently I I don't want to I mean I
have some other bets obviously they're
coming along here my big thing was that
I started when I picked the scores and
he saw them I said damn I'm like with an
appoint and a half of the spread in like
every game except for two or three in
mine I was the same and instead of
having like $50 on those game this week
because I'm sick of losing the
game will stay had up they add up right
and I just said I'm betting ten on those
those coin flip games that I don't know
I'm sick of losing that six weeks to
realize why I do that okay great so the
reason I didn't want to answer your
question before that game was I wanted
you to see that happen first and then I
will say that if my brother does not
want to go with the Houston Texans as
rere to do it's gonna be a problem and I
hold the veto card right now so alright
next game guys the Tennessee Titans five
and four on the road visiting the four
and five Indianapolis Colts spread in
this game Indianapolis - - Chris okay
Wow I knew he had bet pretty big on them
right I was like oh gosh and he's gonna
be so mad when I like you know I trump
him with that one I just I honestly this
is gonna sound really dumb when I lose
all of them but I feel like I kind of
know what's gonna happen in these next
six oh okay let's hear he'll be careful
wish you are alright so Tennessee Titans
okay alright so to me this game has let
down let all over it absolutely let down
all over it all we beat the Cowboys I
think Phil Simms say there's like three
games a year right your emotions get
charged right and I think right
afterwards
yes spent yes is a sprite and I would
say that they probably the emotions
relate that for two weeks in a row you
know right they lost three three in a
row but by week they had to come in on
Monday Night Football game against
Dallas Cowboys that got off to a bad
start everybody seems to forget that
they were a dumpster fire for the first
quarter and a half of that 17 not right
ended up winning but that was an
emotional game then it's the New England
Patriots coming to town
can you can you you know match that
intensity again no it's a real thing
it's it's really hard sometimes to just
you know your backs against the wall
it's the Patriots you can feel the
electricity in the stadium everybody
wants you to beat New England your
coaching staffs from New England they
want so that's hard to live up to that
expectation once again I look at the
Tennessee Titans I think in the their
offense first the Indianapolis Colts
defense I look at another thing and go
man abed worthless the defensive
coordinator for the Colts he's gonna be
able to see what the Cowboys did against
and maybe we're the area's they messed
up in and two weeks ago to change a few
things because he runs a very similar
defense to the Cowboys of course and
then I go from there
I flip it over to the other side of the
ball and hey listen Andrew Luck's one of
the best quarterbacks in football
everybody just better get used to it and
that old line is arguably one of the
best in football as well I have a hard
time thinking that they get a lot of
pass rush on this team and you got to be
careful about blitz and Andrew Luck a
whole lot so I'm only betting I'm
betting ten dollars on the Tennessee
Titans but I'm picking the calls to win
a close one I don't trust the Colts
defense totally yet how dare you
threaten my son Andrew Luck scares the
crap out of me twenty-four twenty-three
twenty-four twenty-fifths win while I
understand keep hitting that lady while
I understand the Colts are not
consistently almost blue that game
against Jacksonville boy were we excited
by the Titans game last week so excited
were a little hung over here in Titan
this Andrew Luck do you know what his
record is against us Titans the last ten
times he's played us his entire career
he's 10 and all is he really the Titans
have never beaten Angela damn he is more
important than the Titans Titans
offensive line is banged up he's quit in
Spain Corey Levin Jack Conklin has
concussions Titans coming off the win of
the year Colts are sitting there all
week going hey Naim hines you gonna
catch this ball hey tight end you're
gonna let that the Jaguars get this
interception I love when a team beats
the crap out of a team in the first half
and holds on to win a close one in the
second half
the coaching moments are there the
Titans have not played a good offense on
the road yet this season right Dallas
Buffalo Jacksonville Miami hmm
wasn't on the roads in London they're
both on the road but the Chargers were
like we'll take a 70 yard touchdown and
then we'll take a 70 yard touchdown
and then we'll take a 70-yard touchdown
I had the Colts winning by four and I
had them winning
I'm putting $100 hello little Andrew
here's some oats look at the Titans are
afraid of us yet again get out of your
stable I love when he he gets shocked
then I bet $10 and then he picked the
other team by just two points to cover
the spread
go ahead to cover this red right root
but I honestly I have I believe that the
Colts will be up in this game 27 to 16
and it's gonna be really comfortable and
then Mariota does this touchdown that
doesn't even matter okay I don't have a
feel for how that plays out totally I
don't know I just I think what you said
is I'm so confident in the Colts offense
right now yeah
and I'm so confident in Andrew Luck and
I look at the Titans and it's just it
just reeks would you bet how much money
a hundred you got a hunch it just reeks
of letdown City it does wriggle it down
City no doubt I also worry about the
Colts secondary matching up with those
receivers but that's the only thing I
mean yeah the cold secondary but it's
not a big thing
all right guys defense is not great now
last game at 1:00 o'clock here the six
and three Carolina Panthers on the road
visiting the three and six Detroit Lions
spread in this game Carolina - for Chris
okay um Carolina of course is going to
be pissed off after that embarrassment
I really do expect them to bounce back I
look at the Detroit Lions and go you
know again their defenses all over the
place they don't defend the run well
they don't defend complete offenses well
and I know they did well against the
Patriots early in the year but the
Patriots are still finding their way I
don't even count some of those games
early in the year really when I think
about these type of matchups you know I
think about the Seattle Seahawks
pounding it down their throat you know I
think about the Bears last week having
people wide open everywhere in the past
game you know I I think about Carolina
being pissed off and going again this is
one of the more complete offenses and I
know with ten days to prepare exactly
the you know again this is not like
statistically one of the top offenses in
football but it's still one of the top
off
fences defend in my opinion and Cam
Newton and the Carolina Panthers have
had a little success against Matt
Patricia and that and I know it's a
different offensive coordinator and all
that but I would also say this is the
most talented Carolina Panthers offense
they've had in a while
I look at Detroit on the other side of
the ball hey their offense is just it's
all over the place is inconsistent would
have a hard time thinking they were just
gonna run the ball down the Carolina
Panthers defense all game long yeah they
do they've lost a serious weapon
certainly and you know again Matt
Stafford hey he makes some good throws
but Matt Stanford's having the worst
year of his career I don't know any
other way to say it I've never seen him
miss some of the throws that he's missed
this year they're just a little
unpredictable to that and that way to me
and I think Carolina is clearly the
better team so because of that I am
taking the Carolina Panthers $80 and I'm
going panthers 31 lions 24 so this was
the one that he took money from to put
on the Houston $20 it was more okay with
an 80 than a 7:30 I've officially lost
my voice because of the time this was a
game that was played last year if you
remember right
Carolina was up 27 to 10
yeah and Matt Stafford led to touchdown
drives to lose 27 24 Detroit was a 2
point favorite in that game and Carolina
was beating their ass
TJ Lang is officially on IR Marvin Jones
did not practice yesterday with a knee
bone bruise and it's legitimate that he
might not play and Darius who might not
by Marvin Jones Marvin Jones geez right
yeah and then Darius slay is limited
with a knee so he might come back after
him missing a lot all right what was
your score in this one I went 20 31 24
Panthers and Chris Simms for the first
time we agree on a score Oh Carolina 31
Detroit 24 and I have $100 on the
Carolina Panthers long hands
you're my friend that is neat yes I and
I feel like I'm just giving Detroit 24
because I didn't want to get too
confident well yeah I get you I mean is
it this is another game where I go if
you really watch Detroit Chicago yeah
the final score was so much better than
how that game actually was Detroit has
looked so bad these last few weeks and
Carolina what we saw that last Thursday
night is not the Carolina Panthers
no they're not and they are gonna come
out much like I believe who else was I
saying is playing with like an axe to
grind Indian like kind of Indianapolis
and stuff I just think Caroline is gonna
come out super super angry now Carolina
hasn't been great on the road
one in three but this just has all the
makings not that hard of a home-field
advantage either this feels like a game
where Cam Newton starts having success
early and he's popping up putting the
first down yeah I Carolina might win
this one by Doubleday I mean that went
through my mind I always get worried
with a team like Detroit and Matt
Stafford you know they they could be up
they could be up 31 to 10 with six
minutes left and they saw touchdowns
right you know just whatever it may be
that's what I always get scared of a
Detroit
all right guys 405 Eastern on Sunday the
three and six Denver Broncos on the road
visiting the seven and to Los Angeles
chargers spread in this game Chargers
minus seven weather in LA on Sunday's
high is 72
partly cloudy Chris okay okay okie I
said that a lot today haven't I um I
don't even know what to say I don't know
what to say you there okay so the Denver
Broncos their defense is still really
good okay that's the one thing I mean we
we have to remember they've had a week
off not to say they're in desperation
mode they're kind of out of it mode
they're kind of trying to finish on a
strong note just so you know they can
maybe save a Vance job joseph's job
something along those lines but I do
think this Denver defense is still a
legitimate force rush the passer you
know of course they have the cover guys
on the back end but I think the biggest
thing that scares me more than anything
you know it's just a complete Chargers
offense and they can beat you more than
one way
and I worry about Denver Broncos run
defense you know that's where I really
get scared in this matchup more than
anything you know I think they can they
can hold their own in the past I worry
about them getting run over in the run
game and then of course then putting and
putting them in some bad positions to
where the big pass plays start to strike
them as well I also look at it on the
other side and just go I do think the
Denver Broncos are gonna be able to move
the ball on the Los Angeles chargers as
well I don't think this is gonna be like
you know the Los Angeles chargers they
have some play makers but it's still not
a great defense when I watch it it's a
good defense there's things that are
encouraging they need Joey Bosa back
badly I think to go up to that next
level of being you know one of the
better defenses in football so because
of that it's not gonna be much of a
home-field advantage I think this game
is somewhat close because the Broncos
defense is good
I'm betting actually $10 on the Broncos
but I think the Chargers win 2721
interesting so when the Chargers are
favored by seven or more their last 15
games are 15 and L when the Broncos have
been underdogs of seven or more their
last 10 their 1 and 9 but against the
spread the Chargers are seven and eight
the Broncos are four and six so it's
really a coin flip when it comes to it
since 2011 the Chargers against the
Broncos they're three and 11 so the
Broncos have actually held this
advantage a little bit and don't forget
the Broncos covered the spread against
the Rams and the Chiefs this year right
what scares me about the Broncos coming
off a bye yeah remember last year when
they came over by I don't they lost to
the Giants where the Giants were all
five here's like a loss of the year so I
think that'll actually help them because
I go remember what happened last year
right I am putting $100 on the Broncos
I love the Broncos in this matchup my
score is Chargers 25 23 Ivan the Broncos
are actually gonna be winning this game
until late and then the Chargers cover I
just want to say this yeah I think you
could tell the way I
talk about the Chargers lately I am
souring on the Chargers they are not a
team that I have a lot of confidence in
I they're a team right now that relies
on big plays and then sometimes when
they have big plays they have huge
penalties that negate those big plays
yeah I just looked at the Chargers right
now against the Broncos I think the
Broncos defense is a lot better than
people think
I think Case Keenum in this offense with
Courtland Sutton and and Emmanuel
Sanders and Phillip Lindsay makin some
cash up this Chargers team I really
believe that but I I would not be
surprised if this was I was really close
to saying take the Broncos to win this
game yeah if I had to pick one team and
a big upset this would be the game that
I would target but I love the Broncos
covering the seven here I think if you
really watch that Chargers Raiders game
boy was I unimpressed with the Chargers
yeah I hear you they live and die by the
big play a little too much like we said
in our Thursday podcast breakdown they
have to find some more cheap easy throws
underneath it can't always be 40 50 yard
runs screen big pass over the top yeah
but I would also argue I think there are
some options underneath
I just don't think Phillip Rivers ever
takes them no he is definitely a and I
don't know how you're gonna go into
Phillip Rivers in year 15 and go hey can
you please hit the check down because I
Philip Rivers is the number one
quarterback in terms of I don't think
he's listening to people well III would
if every quarterback and I would say
he's stubborn Aaron Rodgers I mean he's
certainly been he's certainly I just
hope he would be smart enough to realize
that he's left a few completions on the
field the last few weeks and and they've
gone off the field cuz he hasn't taken
the five-yard under route that would
have got the first down and he threw the
post over the top of the double coverage
they get intercepted whatever it may be
yeah I'm hoping for that but that's the
big hope all right so we're again we've
a disagreed on one game that's crazy
on the topic of Philip Rivers not
listening to people this is a good time
to do this question that we got last
night that we talked about oh yeah the
gentleman five one six is the name
yo Simms yo Simms makes a point on the
floors play call has turned the corner
which is
hopefully true but the discussion right
now is Lafleur said one of the reasons
for the turnaround is that Mariota is
finally telling him when he doesn't like
play calls right
he said the Pats game was like two-way
game calling like a catcher and a
pitcher and he loved it my question is
is that normal do cubies and OCS always
have that relationship and if it is
abnormal is that the McVeigh Shanahan
influence no it's norm it well it's
normal for successful combinations okay
that's what I would tell you yeah
McVeigh Shanahan Sean Payton Sean Payton
is not gonna Drew Brees you're gonna run
this play and you're gonna like it I
mean that's just stupid right I mean
it's stupid not to have that dialogue
and so to give everybody a little bit of
life this issue sounds like Mariota
finally has the guts to talk that's
exactly what it is I wish I had more
guts when I played at times
that's if I look back at it more I go I
should've did had more of an ego
I honestly think that's why when you
talk to athletes after they're retired
they realize then they're like man the
gameís I finally started to make sense
in my career as a lawyers I feel like I
could talk back to my coach and my
career's you're respectful at times you
know and you start to realize like damn
it's you know sometimes some of the guys
are really good or just dicks that's
there's no other way to say and I'd also
say if Phillip Rivers is number one in
quarterbacks that you can't tell
anything I'd say Mariota would be number
32 because I feel like Mariota be like
that's a great idea yeah dreamy polite
yes I know question nope so to further
that answer on a Saturday night before a
game right I would be in a hotel we'd be
in the hotel and Jon Gruden to be the
quarterback meeting right and we would
have the whole play sheet you know 160
plays right there
and we would start to go over the
categories of you know third down passes
right and red zone passes first and
second down passes like and we would
start to go through the different
categories you know 12 personnel 11
whatever it was we would start to crack
away and he would read off the place and
asked me if I liked them or not or give
me your five favorite that would be the
first thing you'd say give me your five
favorite and I'd go I like play number
four
I like play number seven I like play
number nine and you know he took Oh
you don't like pipe 15 you know and I
think now I just I'm not feeling it or
we've only got to practice it like two
times the last month and I just don't
feel comfortable with it or I don't
trust this receiver and that's that
route whatever it may be but that is
normal dialogue and you have to have
that what is the football equivalent of
a pitcher saying no to a catcher does
that happen during the game at all cuz
you can't talk back to the coach no
youyou can't yeah there's I don't know
audible at the line of scrimmage you
just say I'm doing it yeah I mean but I
don't even know that ten you saw
something you call that really I think
the yeah the equivalent would be this
and only really the guys that have
earned the stripes to do that would be
pretending like they don't I don't hear
you I don't under you right are you
serious yeah that would be the
equivalents the only way other than that
I would say you maybe some dialogue on
the sidelines where you would just go
don't call that I know I'm not loving
that play yeah but other than that yeah
that's the only thing you can do
gotcha you know and and really you you
know the audible thing you know you
better have a reason to audible like a
legitimate reason because if it goes bad
man you're gonna be in the doghouse all
week gotcha
all right guys moving on next game 405
on Sunday the one and eight Oakland
Raiders on the road visiting the two and
seven Arizona Cardinals spread in this
game is Arizona minus five Christian
this game is our weekly let's spend
twenty minutes discussing this game yeah
it won't take me twenty so here we go
alright the Oakland Raiders offense it's
not that great we know that the Chargers
defense I don't know Cardinals defense
is very good okay Chandler Jones there's
a clip of Patrick mahomes after the game
be like yo your guys defense is really
really good it's it's Shawn McDermott
ish Buffalo like we talked about on our
third Thursday podcast they both came
from Carolina Wilkes is great at
breaking down offenses and going when
they get in this formation be aware of
these combinations and they kind of
route read off of that so that allows
their players to play really fast and
zone know what to expect they're really
sound football team on defense and they
got a few playmakers I mean paddy P is
still really good I would say Chandler
Jones is one of the best passers in
football and I don't know what to expect
from the Raiders offense I really don't
and it's just not that impressive at
this point physically as player
or the schematics of it either now you
flip it around to the other side yeah of
course I'm not in love with the Raiders
defense either I'm not I don't know what
else to say you know and I don't love
the Arizona offense but I at least look
at that and go there's a few playmakers
there and they're turning in a rack
exactly right David Johnson's getting
the freakin rock no doubt about it
and you know I like Rosen when people
are Auburn he hits them is he done you
know David Johnson like you talked about
is so Larry for fits and you know
there's no I'm not gonna say it's a good
group of weapons but it's respectable
and because of that I'm betting ten
dollars on the Raiders but I don't think
they're gonna win the game just win baby
win more than once this year okay
but yeah I'm picking the Cardinals to
win 22:17
mmm I'm not betting big money on these
type of games I get you yeah I
understand
martavis Bryant is out Jordy Nelson is
questionable after a week in which a lot
of people thought he was going to retire
because it doesn't sound like he wants
to be there anymore
Colet CEO semele Rodney Hudson didn't
practice they're really banged up the
Raiders are the worst team in the NFL
against the spread you know what the
Cardinals are against the spread this
year it's probably it's really good
obvious I've won in one room and I love
them at home Arizona at home is one of
those beautiful things they're not gonna
get a pass rush on Josh Rosen they're
not even with the banged up Arizona
offensive line how are they only five
one-on-one I don't know I have seven
okay before about the Brad skins in Rams
game you're not counting those two early
buckles guys you got you got you I I
think Arizona wins this game twenty four
to ten I don't think Arizona's offense
is great but I don't think that
Oakland's offense us I think that
Oakland's offense with martavis Bryant
and Jalen Rashard and Jared cook they
have enough weapons to go ooh they're
kind of scary yeah but I think when you
lose martavis Bryant you lose a huge
weapon that offense with martavis Bryant
is different because he's a difference
maker yes but I really like Arizona Here
I am going 100 dollars on the Arizona
Cardinals Rosen one here on the road
he's on the Rosen bandwagon Hart well
I'll tell you man just watch them
against Kansas City I was very impressed
you should been the last few we
what he's done by by what they've been
able to focus on and even the routes
like when you see the highlights and you
see David Johnson on that wheel route at
the top or yeah the way they're using
Larry Fitzgerald he's they're not I felt
like with Mike McCoy they were sitting
on the outside and they were running a
traditional offense and now I'm seeing
so many different flow right that I like
Arizona a lot now five is a lot and
that's why I was gonna go more and I'm
definitely not left go lucky I don't
want to put that much in Arizona but all
week I'm free
Oakland is awful yeah it seems the the
optics are horrible for the Raiders
I like betting against the team that
quits because when you quit in the NFL
then you get blown the FL yeah
all right guys for 25o Sunday I bet it
on Oakland $10 because I just couldn't
go with the more than the five points
yep 425 on Sunday the 4 & 5 Philadelphia
Eagles on the road visiting the 8 & 1
seeds spread in this game New Orleans -
8 and I think for this one we should let
left go ahead yeah lead it off with your
squad
Ronald Darby is out Jalen Mills did not
practice Lane Johnson was limited in
practice but Sydney Jones supposed to be
back Marcus Davenport and Terron
Armstead are going to be out the Saints
are going to move the ball at will
against the Eagles in the passing game I
believe they're gonna have to wear them
down as the game goes on to establish
the run but I will tell you this the
Eagles offense I feel very confident
will be the second half Eagles offense
not the first half Eagles offense it was
the Eagles out of a buy last week but
once that started clicking and Zach arts
Zach Ertz started getting featured and
Alshon Jeffery starting at the Paul I
expect Golden Tate to get the ball more
the last four times the Saints have been
favored by seven or more there Owen four
against the spread I see the Saints
winning this game
31 to 27 that's an Eagles cover and I'm
going $100 on the Eagles plus eight yeah
lose by a little there's no chance
you'll win this game okay okay okay
that's enough that's good man it's
amazing how that Titan thing really took
your voice away it's unbelievable it
really killed you when you go against
the Titans right it's like the Titan
this week apparently was Ursula yeah she
took my voice she strike if yes you made
a lot of good people any chance the
Eagles can win this game
I don't think so yeah I really don't
that's not like not betting but like you
just straight up winning it I think it
would take a miraculous performance by
Carson Wentz in the passing game is
there any chance I can use a narrative
that you used earlier about the Packers
right where think about the important
games the Saints have had to play and
back to back to back to back weeks I
mean they come in Sean Payton had to
smash the the fire it last week but
there was the Rams the Vikings the
Ravens he'll smash something else this
week yeah I don't think that's why he's
a great coach do you think they went by
the poker is on their ass he knows that
the Rams are lurking he doesn't wanna
have to go to LA and play them out there
and he lost out there last year the
Saints get a home-field advantage to the
playoffs right just booked them to the
Superbowl I mean it's gonna be really
tough I don't see anyone going in there
it may be the Rams because actually
right so you know I yeah I think this is
a horrible matchup for your Eagles team
you know that of course the go ahead
what do you want say just ask all right
but the Eagles yeah the Eagles pass-rush
it's not as good as last year your D
lines not as good as last year okay so
that you can't send waves of guys I mean
you really don't have anybody that pops
says just a singular guy off the edge
right now where I go man he's he's on
fire he's kicking but it's all about
Fletcher Cox and really after that
Michael Bennett's the second-best e
linemen on the team right now you know I
worry of course about your defensive
scheme there's always exposures every
week in some shape or form bed of the
year Jim Schwartz gets fired I would
think it's certainly certainly lining up
that way and now you're gonna play a
team that's got nine million different
formations and concepts not only in the
pass game but there's another nine
million in the run game so I just don't
see how that side of the ball like I
think you're
your deal I know hang tough like what
you said in some of the run game but I
think it's just the constant of barrage
of everything that will wear down the
Eagles defense now I look on the other
side too and go hey I think the Eagles
offense will be able to throw the ball a
little bit on the New Orleans Saints
I certainly do I don't just think
they're gonna just you know roll over or
get steamrolled there but you know again
the big thing there's two things that
have changed about the Eagles can't run
the ball like they did last year you
know everyone's good looking at I heard
somebody on TV today go well their
offensive stats are the same as last
year's this year no they're not they're
total yards per game are the same but
last year you were the sixth best
running team in football this year
you're 27th or somewhere along those
lines other thing is last year you were
one of the best turnover margin teams in
football this year you're not your
defense doesn't create as many plays and
your offense has had a dumb mistake here
they're in some big situations so I'm
putting $100 on the Saints I did I just
I looked at it like with $10 to all that
and the Saints favored by 8 over the
Eagles I are feeling Kyle like I know
thank you yeah this is gonna be a $200
swing to eat into that I feel like I'll
I know these teams I feel comfortable
with it and I guess what I feel
comfortable is you know I think this
game will be somewhat close to a degree
for a little bit here and there but I
just think at the end of the day they're
gonna wear them out I could see it being
like a 24 21 game and now the same
doesn't play yeah I'm screwed if he does
I think the Eagles cover yeah I mean
it's it could be a contender 24 21 what
was your score 31 21
mmm I just think they're gonna wear them
out and then you're gonna get that drive
at the end that's so you don't think
this Saints trains ever gonna slow down
no it's not the Saints are one of the
best teams in football I don't think
there's ever a team other than the 2007
Patriots that don't slow down III didn't
mean I don't know I mean did Carolina so
mad that I might think the Eagles win
this came out right and shocked the were
put your money where your mouth is I
already did would you would you bet on
your stuff
did we both have a hundred okay you got
it on the Saints I got on the Eagles I
got an eight-point cushion right but oh
look the Saints are the much better team
but I could see some deflected passes I
am with the Eagles Fletcher Cox he's had
the game of his life but as you always
say with that offensive line he probably
won't I it's hard for me to think he's a
nobody [ __ ] I think Carson Wentz is
gonna be able to put up points this week
yeah okay I get you there that's my I
get you I'm not I'm not like listen I
don't think this is like blah I like
this is thirty one to seven this is in
Houston wash and Philadelphia had a
climb back in the game no I think this
game is gonna go back and forth yeah you
had 3121 I had 31 27 so I just have a
little score weights where they go for
two I'm thinking late score the other
way they're up 24 21 they have a
5-minute drive at the end of the game
punch one more in and see if Philly all
right guys moving on to Sunday Night
Football the five three and one
Minnesota Vikings on the road visiting
the six and three Chicago Bears spread
in this game is Chicago - two and a half
and whether in Chicago on Sunday night
low of 24 but clear skies I like it that
way I love watching some Chicago
cold-weather football breath coming out
yeah it's just awesome that's what like
I've told you before I know you guys
have heard me I love the bear Stadium I
really do it's one of my favorite in
football and I love the bear fans I love
them I mean they are so invested in the
game and they're really cool you want to
know how invested the Bears are yeah a
local news station right because Cody
Park II missed four kicks
and they hit the post each time right
flew a helicopter over practice during
Cody parkies kicking session so that
they can update Bears fans on how many
kicks he's making and missing there's
not a lot of cities that are gonna do
that now because having worked in local
news do you know what it takes to fly
the chopper up the only time you fly the
chopper up is if you have a high speed
chase or like it just doesn't go up a
lot they led the newscast do you know
how hard it is to lose a newscast with
sports you got to be a sports craze city
to fly up there for the kicker they love
their football team and I believe they
were gonna make the kick your GoPro
to set the stadium that's where he was
for a while why they flew the helicopter
sorry sorry I didn't mean to I don't
know first thing I didn't know if you're
talking at the stadium part of it which
i think is really cool and that's next
level and that's what they should do
anyways so okay this is a really a great
matchup I'm extremely excited to watch
this football game so - you know it's
it's it's gonna be in the elements
triple you know typical NFC North
football
both teams are tough you got the number
four and five defenses in football
matching up against each other I think
that's awesome
I mean you know it's really there's a
lot of even things here across the way
so I don't feel necessarily comfortable
in any type of bet when I think about
this game I'm not just going oh this
team's gonna win and I feel good about
it and let's end this discussion right I
think games being ended in the last five
minutes
III would agree - I would agree with
that as well I think the the big thing
to me I just look at it it's in Chicago
okay
as much as Minnesota's from Minnesota
they do play indoors okay I give the
Bears a little advantage there I think
the other thing I look at is I give the
Bears offense the advantage in the
matchups or just because of their
overall creativity and they have more
weapons and things to worry about number
one thing I thought about was yes Sims
believes the Vikings offense is simple
right there facing Vic Fangio exactly
right the Bears offense is complex and
we always know where Minnesota's
defenders are going to be exactly that's
that's really that's where that's where
I was going with it and and hey am I you
know hey Kirk Cousins throwing two
Thielen and digs I mean hey that's one
of the it's one of the best combinations
or you know three ways and football
right now and if you know that that
could change things but it is a little
too dependent on that still to me and I
got to see this Minnesota run game a
little bit more a talent Cooke is back
100% right which would be great there's
a nice addition to their team but I
think a lot of this bears defense and
especially when there's a healthy Kyle
Mack on this defense so I am a wimp here
I'm betting ten dollars on the Bears
I've expect them to win the game 23 to
20
I also have the Bears scoring 23 but I
have the Vikings scoring 24 so I have
the Vikings winning this game and I
believe that the Bears are the better
team right now I believe that they
should win the game but sometimes you
got to pick ups and the Bears at home in
their last 15 games against the spread
it's a beautiful place to play they're
11 and 5 but the Vikings in their last
10 games away there I'm against the
spread 8 and 2 I think that this is a
very interesting matchup where I love
the Bears defense and I I agree with you
about the matchups but I think that Kirk
Cousins is having that special game yeah
ok I trust Kirk more than I trust
Mitchell absolutely sure and I know that
Anthony bar was did not practice and
there's a chance he's gonna miss this
game but Dalvin cook being back I'm very
excited to see yeah I think that
Minnesota is feeling a little desperate
because they're seeing the bear is
starting to extend their lead and I
think that they're gonna come out there
I I think the Vikings win this game with
less than four minutes left but I want
to give you something here about the
Bears defense yeah they've knocked one
quarterback out of the game this year
Aaron Rodgers they've knocked three
quarterbacks out of a job Ryan
Fitzpatrick Sam Bradford Nathan Peterman
and they've knocked two quarterbacks out
of the league Sam Bradford Nathan
Peterman this season that was from Mark
potage which I thought is an awesome
awesome tweet great one so yeah I had
the Vikings winning this game one it's
just a tight game and I have morning at
24 23 I'm taking the team getting the
point I'm excited you hundred hundred so
so we are we have now disagreed three in
a row you're taking Oakland because you
think too many points with Arizona
you're taking New Orleans you think they
can cover and you're taking Chicago and
I think it's AI untape I think that's a
one two point game yeah I don't even
think it's a field goal game and also
I'm gonna be honest
their field goal kicker has to go and
practice in the stadium in the middle of
the week yeah so I'm gonna take like
good those points are gonna be valuable
and that guy's probably in his freaking
head what is all over your bets with the
Oakland and
goggle games I mean all these hundred
and all of them okay I feel really
confident good all right guys last game
of the week Monday Night Football no
longer in Mexico City the Kansas City
Chiefs on the road visiting the Los
Angeles Rams and that's changed the line
it has spread in this game is Los
Angeles - three and a half was
originally originally the line opened at
railay - one la - one so they thought in
a neutral field the Rams were one point
favorite and that jumped up two and a
half points since it went home oh go
teams in this game nine in one Chris
break it down for all right um no really
Oh everyone no awesome game okay
I really would be shocked if it doesn't
live up to the billing I really would
you know I know we talked about another
Thursday podcast you know sometimes in
these type of games where you think
there's gonna be a shootout
the defense does things that they you
know haven't done all year because they
feel like they got to get an advantage
somehow some way you know the offense
feels the pressure to match the other
team that might happen early but I think
it's only a matter of time before the
floodgates open for both teams I really
do I mean these are two of the most
talented offenses in football they're
two of the better play designers in all
of football
I'd give Shawn McVeigh a little bit of
the advantage as far as a play designer
over all the weapons though I'd probably
give Kansas City the advantage you know
if you mail back yeah quarterback
running back I take early next receiver
I take Tyree kill tight end I take
Kelsey next receiver I'd probably take
woods over walkins I would take one it's
very close but I would he's ramming a
well around Rams took was over Watkins -
yes well they didn't want to pay walk
offensive line offensive line I'd
probably go with the ran I would - yeah
defensive line obviously Rams
yes linebackers Rams yeah I mean
whatever countin I'm counting D Ford
yeah I'm going Rams
secondary I'm going rims kicker
I'm gonna go chiefs I guess so having
thought about that hunter Rams for sure
coaching staff on offensive coaching
staff you're going right Rams and of
course one offensive coach I'm going
Rams as well special teams coach I'm
rams as well I'm going Dave towel I
think this that it's a great special
it's a great matchup I'm very curious if
there's a team has to punt
what kind of fakes we're gonna see in
this game no they're gonna be all over
each other I see some onside kicks
you're gonna see some detailed special
team stuff because these guys they take
it personal when they get burned by some
guy on a fake thing like that's a real
issue right like the special teams
coordinator when you screw him over with
a trick play he's ruined for six days
like ruined so again I think this is
gonna be awesome
either way I boiled it down like this
I'm just gonna get to my bet
I'm betting $10 on the Kansas City
Chiefs okay
the point the 0.5 would the 0.5 scared
me okay
I think the Rams are going to win this
game 34 to 31 and I just went down to
one reason I think the Rams got a few
more playmakers on defense that's the
only reason I did it you know Donald sue
Peters the speed at linebacker
LaMarcus Joyner I just think that
combinations a little bit better than
Kansas City but I don't feel comfortable
that that's either way I could see this
game being 34 31 and the chief saver as
well seth wickersham just wrote a very
big article about patrick mahomes and
diving into the notion what's it like to
have an arm that people have never seen
before in the article one thing that
came up is that patrick mahomes puts
ketchup on everything but he's getting
embarrassed to do so because everybody
knows who he is now and it got to the
point where even at dinner he's sitting
there with a steak and his mom will
secretly put the ketchup under the table
go just put it on the steak because he's
embarrassed to do it came out today
he puts ketchup on mac and cheese that's
pretty gross it's pretty gross but it's
unconventional right and so's mahomes is
a football player yeah I think the
Chiefs win this game 38 to 35 and I'm
putting $200 on the Kansas City Chiefs
here's my main reason yeah we can look
at the defense we can look at the wide
receivers we can look at the tight ends
you know what I'm looking at the most
light every time that I watched Jared
Goff in a prime-time game it ain't the
same as Jared Goff in a regular game
Jared Goff is really good but I still
see moment that Thursday night primetime
game against the Vikings
he was really good I get it I got it but
there are still moments where I go if
there's pressure on him they're playing
the number one sack team in the NFL in
the Kansas City cheater when he needs to
run out of the pocket or he gets someone
on him it's still he still crumples like
he still has a little bit of that Eli in
the pocket yours going my Holmes that's
what you like better about it I have
seen mahomes yeah in the primetime games
and when the pressures on the kid gets
better and I don't care what Sean
McVeigh's telling him when he's in a
legitimate shootout legitimate shootout
because he wasn't worried about the
Vikings keeping it going like I just got
so much confidence in my homes and I
have confidence in Kareem hunt I trust a
knee read more than I trust Sean McVeigh
ok I trust my home's more than I trust
Jared Goff and for either of these teams
to be favored by three and a half to me
is crazy like I just it's a lot of
points I don't know you disagree well I
just think there's too many I'm going
$200 too many ifs I mean you went
through the checks and you said all that
you said you went with the Rams more
checks than the Chiefs I mean I get it I
know I guess I don't really get it I
don't but that's ok I don't know you
know what Saints like Rams
yeah sounds a lot like Saints like Rams
where he was awesome and a shootout on
the road in a game Jared got the guy you
were just saying wasn't good I know it's
all I'm saying just don't challenge
lying out there yeah I kind of took
unnecessary shots I'd like to apologize
to my doppelganger jared confidence
unnecessary I guess for me you're just
going with mahomes you think he's gonna
make magic that's fine that's cool I get
it I'm I just couldn't put $200 on i'm
also hope that for me it was i just
looked at the game and saw
the Chiefs could win this game yeah and
their three and a half point underdogs
yeah yeah I mean I don't feel great
normally it takes like twenty four hours
for left go to start questioning it
because it feels exactly like your Rams
I mean you're you're great to pick the
game I just think your money is like
it's off it doesn't match your thoughts
but no change in now you're screwed you
said I'd like to take that money you
want to put on Houston Washington do you
want to watch this game together on
Monday night I'd like to be with you for
this one Oh
Monday night like all of us to watch
this game we will watch yes let's what
do we have this week yeah I will be in
Las Vegas Oh
Hyundai your cuz I am gonna be in Las
Vegas Tuesday it's all out now so I can
announce it good Tuesday I'm gonna be in
Las Vegas for the match which is Phil
Mickelson versus Tiger Woods Tuesday I'm
hosting the press conference I've got a
beautiful maroon blazer that I'm gonna
be rocking and then Friday I am doing
the pregame show for the match and on
the set I have Pat Perez the Charles
Barkley of golf right I have Charles
Barkley right and samuel l.jackson that
is awesome that's insane um please text
the group when you're on and things just
let me know that's all I want to see
everything my flight is at 7 o'clock on
Monday
hope you got DirecTV what airline you're
flying you know I'm gonna check right
gotta be Delta you just Delta have
DIRECTV they usually depending on the
pennant betting on the plane which I
would think would be a pretty good plane
going out on that long just this trip
well Vegas is a little shorter Vegas is
only like five hours so sometimes you
don't I've been on Vegas flights without
it yeah I can't believe that this was
happening
USA Today article and the fact that I'm
realizing this right freaking now I just
are you kidding me I'm doing Monday
night hanging out with you now screw
left go watch the game
oh my wait awesome so are you buying
Delta I think so are you when are you
gonna wear your pants that have Tigers
on it on the show I know which one is on
Wednesday Friday yeah I'll text you when
it's on all right and we're gonna do
we're gonna do left go memes because we
mess with you whenever you're on TV I'm
gonna take a
million screenshots and videos of left
gun what is uh okay and then all right
just so I get I had it fly to fly SDL's
at Delta yes alright so there's a good
chance I would say your preset yeah you
should bet two hundred on it if I miss
I'm gonna be on the plane you know what
I was supposed to do a lot of
preparation okay gang go do no work um
ha ha you know what this means left go
is gonna be asking me to movie boy he's
gonna have a Boeing account there's that
boying or Boingo hotspot and go hotspot
and he's gonna be Boingo hotspot in you
like a no I'm gonna well if I can get
Boingo I'll watch the game but then I
have to like you can't stream a game
it's a game of the year and it's
freaking Joe tessitura my ear going so V
but I really hope you don't have the
game I really do I hope you said a text
to us like in the first quarter asking
for an update it doesn't come through in
the bullying hotspot to like the third
quarter the Boeing hotspot all right
guys before we wrap up the show here
real quick recap here on the
disagreements and the big bets I can't
believe you're gonna miss that game
Thursday Night Football Sims you have
200 on Seattle left go you only have 50
on Seattle moving to the one o'clock
games on Sunday Sims 750 bleacher bucks
on Houston left go has 150 disagreements
this week Sims you are going with the
Titans left go you were going with the
Colts yeah Sims you are going with the
Raiders left go you are going with the
Cardinals yeah
Sims you are going with the Saints left
go with the Eagles and the final
disagreement of the week Sims you are
going with the Bears left go you are
going with the Vikings Monday Night
Football you both picked KC Sims has to
since has 10 bucks on the Chiefs left go
has 200 for my left Kolak Sims what do
you think I think I'm gonna go
Pittsburgh - five-and-a-half okay I'm
tell me the rest of them I'm definitely
going Houston yep we got today I think
I'm gonna go indie okay and I think I'm
gonna go Carolina there's four right in
the middle right is there any of those
other ones that I like I like Denver
plus seven but I don't really want my
luck maybe I should do that but I I
agree not really lock in Arizona not
gonna lock Philly well but your bets you
should be locking Kansas City
yeah I probably should I mean if you
feel that way but I don't want to be the
influencer when the I feel mad like I
feel bad about the Elena one last week
and I saw you made that a lock and I
like I actually was thinking about you
is there is losing I was I'm and I went
so hard and left or that I said which
one scares you the most
Tennessee in Indy to Tennessee an Indy
scares me just because Mariota played
well for me when I love rock game dude
do you man I don't know what to say okay
we got one thing to do before we wrap it
up here hold on I need to think about
this for a sec all right you're right
Josh there is only one thing left to do
what's that for the last five weeks
Chris Sims has been someone that you can
bet your life on your money your spirit
your pride last week an unfortunate
event happened Cleveland and Tennessee
all took mass amounts of growth hormones
just to ruin Chris's but now I bring you
the Oracle guaranteed to lose first Sims
we go to the Steel City right but in the
V in Jacksonville hello Jacksonville
you're not Saxon ville this year you're
going to lose and guaranteed to lose
this dealers are coming to town they're
better than you Ramsey talk crap about
Big Ben they got the best of the
Steelers twice last year and I don't
believe in anything in Jacksonville
right now the offense is unpredictable
and not that great and the defense who I
love so much has been a disaster I'm
taking Jacksonville guaranteed to lose
your Stang with this music huh next up I
guess I got to fit this mold guaranteed
to lose Sims his lock of the week lock
of the week
Redskins verse Texans ha ha ha ha ha
have you seen the Redskins offensive
line ha
haha have you seen JJ merciless and
clowny they cometh to the DC area to
over hang no wow she didn't Redskins and
their bad offense Texans win Redskins
lose I guarantee and I look into this or
but I wonder who Oracle take next and I
see a city in the Midwest take your orb
city in the Midwest you are Detroit live
oh the Oracle has spoken I have spoken
lyons you will lose because Superman is
coming to town and they are pissed off
they've had extra days and the Lions run
defense stinks you will lose to the
Carolina Panthers the rivers will run
red with the Lions blood I look back at
crime I'd like to remind you I then look
into the orb for the Oracles fourth team
guaranteed to lose and I'm seeing myself
I want to see yourself
I see a fleur-de-lis oh I see another
crack in the Bell oh no oh no open
Adelle be a girl ooh oh no let go things
you gotta lose Sharon let go things
you're gonna lose she actually doesn't
think they're gonna lose this week how
dare you Sharon don't you go against me
on the Oracle Bruce let go does he think
they lose possibly possibly sorry Billy
the Saints are awesome
all right I like this I'm looking into
the orb four of the guarantees have been
made one guarantee remains and all I see
is a horse what does that mean
it means it's she'll get strike if by
lightning
Broncos you shall lose to the Chargers
your run defense is not good I don't
trust the run defense I don't trust that
Case Keenum do take care of that
football it may be a home game for you
in the Los Angeles area but this is the
Chargers here and they shall win these
games this year
sorry Denver you lose them the five
teams guaranteed to lose have been set
the Oracle has spoken
Jacksonville goodbye Washington see you
later
Detroit good to know yeah
Denver good riddance and Philadelphia
will likely prove you wrong I'm sorry ah
man that was a good one I like that we
changed it up I think we should
literally ask to change it up last week
I know I forgot yeah I think we should
have a new theme every week can we do
that like whatever you need just let me
know and yeah well silliest thing we do
all week
yeah I just yeah what theme do you want
next week I don't know just go with it
let's just go with it whatever it is
whatever you guys whatever Nikki gee
thanks Nikki gue you got it man it's all
you I can't wait I also thought about I
really wanted to pick the Packers and
guaranteed to lose I just couldn't do it
Oh for Thursday night yeah I thought
about the rare Thursday night GTL where
the viewers get to see it Friday morning
I know you did it one other time this
year I think I think you're right - got
it I can't remember I think was with it
I don't know
was but all right so my getting back to
it what are we gonna do Monday night for
watching the game I don't know you tell
me you want to go not here I'll go get
some welcome steaks and the city goes
missing game of the year for match of
the year yeah right all right wrap up
this podcast all right that was good hit
us up as always at Sims and love go on
social vendrick will be manning the DM
z-- and letting me know when appropriate
but of as always for Sims
he's down homies Hedrick would say good
evening in the le f k OE man oh damn try
again the lef koe man says holla holla
holla holla holla holla holla if delta
doesn't have this game i'm going to
freak out on a plate could everyone
tweet at delta and ask for the monday
night flight to Vegas to have DIRECTV on
the plane let go would appreciate it
holy crap alright see ya
games of the year